normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is a really really big story from uh
earlier today Israel demands action
after journalists reportedly joined
Hamas Massacre AP CNN Reuters and the
New York Times They had reporters this
is a an investigative I'm sorry this is
the uh here we go honest reporting is a
i gu an NGO that it it pushes back on
article that it says are posting fake
news about Israel and they have some
photos taken by Hassan
Esa at the conflict and there are
serious questions any editor should have
asked about these photos excuse me good
sir uh uh reporter that we are paying
how did you get this photo Hamas is
allowing you to film their operations
how did you know to film in these
locations were you with Hamas what did
did they tell you now there's serious
real There's real questions would we
rather have the photos or not my concern
is if these quote unquote reporters are
embedded with Hamas there's a photo they
actually have a photo of one of the guys
with one of the Hamas leaders holy yeah
like they look like friends and so it
would seem the images and photos that
came out were intentionally released by
Hamas to control the narrative and if
these news organizations paid these
individuals they were directly funding h
yeah I'm not surprised cuz these are the
same corporate corporate press people
who were funding BLM and basically
embedded with them and helping burn down
and they have young progressives on
staff who would think this is Justified
I mean we saw this in the US there's no
reason to think it's not happening in
the newsrooms everywhere when I saw this
story today I I thought of I forget his
full name but I think the last name was
Sullivan and he was the guy at j6 who
was selling his footage uh from inside
the capital and it was on CNN yeah he
made a bunch of money and then like
he's on video waving the knife like
doing like instigating literal bad stuff
you know so I I see you know this is
just the next step for these people this
is what they do but I would like to know
who they are like uh to what de degree
did they partake in this I do want to
see the photos and then I want to be
able to judge for myself uh but like are
they Freelancers did they know the
publication beforehand do we know that
are they are they retainer Freelancers
right did the New York Times apnn as
organizations know the attack was going
to happen I gotta be honest I think it's
entirely possible totally think they're
claiming they don't they're saying we
had no idea is going to happen well they
have to say that but look what does it
mean for an organization to say we
didn't know does that mean an editor
didn't know it's entirely possible one
of these guys contacted their you know
buyer whatever and said look there's
going to be a major military action on
the 7th I can get you the photos you
know here's how much I want negotiated
the question that we that needs to be
asked the deeper investigation is
how quickly were these photos released
because if they were released instantly
that means a pre-existing relationship
was in play and these guys are likely on
some kind of retainer or payroll or at
the very least sent an email saying
check out these photos do you want to
buy them and they immediately just said
yes without question here's a photo
Palestinian Palestinian militants from
Gaza Strip run the Gate of uh uh kibutz
kafar Aza on
Saturday uh uh from run run by the gate
so is this a photo of them appear
appearing to try and get
in could this
reporter have warned someone they were
about to go and and kill a bunch of
civilians is it the duty of the reporter
to do so I mean these are serious moral
questions yes and uh unless he's
ideologically aligned with Hamas in
which case he is a propaganda mouthpiece
of Hamas that is being paid by the
American corporate press it's one thing
to embed yourself with a thing and and
and report on it but it's another
another thing to I think you have it's e
ethically you must say something if you
know that's going to happen yeah doesn't
matter how embedded you are that's
ridiculous the but like when that
picture of him kissing the kissing
picture like is that from beinged
October 6th like when is that picture
even from that it matters it could be
from years ago but uh I mean only
matters because Hamas has spent a lot of
time trying to embed themselves in the
good graces of progressives in America I
mean what was the line from you know I
think it was a 2019 interview where he
was saying you know equating basically
the Hamas and their actions to BM and
George Floyd right and he used those
words because he knows that there is an
emotional reaction on the American left
this is a long-standing uh goal of Hamas
in my observational understanding of it
that they want the American left
journalism class to be sympathetic to
them totally and so it wouldn't be
surprising me if a journalist has a
positive relationship with both uh a
western outlet and Hamas and Hamas was
like yeah come here let's do it and I
don't know if that journalist is
objective enough to understand what they
are consenting to or what they are
enabling with their actions what media
Outlet was it that said they were bombed
by Israel years ago but it turns out
they were in the headquarters of Hamas
that that time do you remember that
story there were it was a there was a
media center right that it was claimed
just where reporters are and then it
came out that Hamas used the a sublevel
for weapons and stuff yes yeah because
that's what they do yeah and we all do
it like this country's got bad bad press
or working with our bad agents all the
time you know I do think it's funny cuz
like the US has blown up and killed a
bunch of people at weddings in Pakistan
and things like that you know what I
mean exactly come on so you know I I
just I just can't stand the uh the
hypocrisy more importantly I mean look
the these these corporate corporate news
organizations they're evil they are big
faceless corporations the only thing
that editor was thinking was I can't get
in trouble but we get these photos out
it's big how much do you want they
didn't didn't even stop to say how did
you get these photos cuz look man if it
turns out that you're working with these
guys we can't give you any money for
this m it's even worse than if he says
okay you can take him for free because
that means you are are putting out the
propaganda they want released and I
think you know a lot of people say why
would they want that that release
showing of the horrible things they're
doing you know they filmed themselves
doing horrible things they published
this footage they wanted to destroy the
Abraham Accords and shift negotiating
power back to to Palestine by saying hey
look we're crazy
and Biden gave him $100 million yep yeah
it's crazy I would advise recommend
anyone who cares about what's going on
behind the scenes at corporate media
places to watch the best movie network
and it goes through I'm mad as all and
I'm not going to take it anymore that's
it you know and how they exploit uh
violence Madness you know and what what
they do for the clicks for the views
it's one of my favorite movies one of
the best written movies with the best
dialogue ever but I think that movie
even though I came out in probably the'
7s or 80s it is just as uh relevant
today as it was then yeah I I think it's
unsurprising that this happening I am
curious what the response would be from
AP or Reuters whoever put out the photos
because ultimately they control the news
so even if they put out a statement they
can bury it as fast as anything else did
CNN fired the guy did they say what
capacity he work with
them well let's let's read this from the
messenger they say uh CNN other
organizations blah blah blah blah blah
and uh let's see
in a statement posted X the Israeli
Prime Minister said this okay come on
come on CNN told Israeli Outlet wet that
it had severed ties with esia in the
wake of the honest reporting
investigation saying we are aware of the
article and photo concerning Hassan Esa
a freelance photo journalist who has
worked with a number of international
and Israeli Outlets CNN wrote in a
statement oh yeah while we have not at
this time found reason to doubt the
journalistic accuracy of the work he's
done for us we have decided to suspend
all ties with him the network added that
kind of sounds like they're saying holy
crap we're in trouble cut cut ties with
him and and dismiss it yeah because if
if if it really wasn't nothing they
would say look it's a freelancer we've
worked with in the past we have no
comment that's what I was thinking is
that he's this guy is probably not like
a direct employee of CNN it's probably
not that so he's a freelancer so are the
news companies just the middleman and
then maybe someone's calling and saying
hey we got someone over there right
maybe doesn't matter
because you can't legally give material
support to a terrorist organization so
the questions that are rising with with
this is look this is not an instance
where photos emerged of someone in the
music festival who had been there and
said look I was here in Israel I was
filming this is a guy who's Palestinian
in Gaza who has photos from inside
Israel meaning he breached the barriers
with he that like he's with the guy the
the bigger question is did these media
organizations pay Hamas for the
propaganda material Hamas wanted
released mhm yeah I think that's a big
problem this I think this ethically is
just a giant nightmare you know uh and
it reminds me of this weird story about
this there's this journalist from back
in the day was in the new journalism
movement wrote a lot of great stories
and then in his old years uh he he wrote
a story about a guy with a motel who was
a Voyer looking at the people who were
in his hotel rooms and then he embedded
himself with that person and like me
reading that I'm like ethically you
should be warning everybody about this
but instead he's like cozying up to this
guy looking through the pee Pooles mhm
the AP claims the first pictures they
received show they were taken more than
an hour after the attacks began no AP
staff were at the border uh at the time
of the attacks nor did any AP staff
cross the border at that time that does
not mean this guy was not there and
people are posting a video showing one
of these reporters holding a grenade or
something like this that's what's what's
being reported on next and uh yo Israel
is saying these these journalists are
going to be treated as terrorists that's
crazy as Lion now says he fears for his
life those who stood quote as Idol
bystanders while children were
slaughtered are no different than
terrorists and should be treated as such
that's crazy man see this is where it
gets interesting I don't like do if this
guy's a legitimate journalist and he's
not with Hamas do we want these photos
we want to see what they're doing yes
unfortunately but yes but the question
is is he actually aligned with them and
are news organizations paying a guy and
providing material support to the
propaganda wing of Hamas that's the
problem I got to be honest I don't think
anyone operates in Gaza without the
approval of Hamas I don't think this guy
could be a journalist without them like
a Palestinian journalist in Gaza they
know who he is they have to he's selling
photos of the AP being played
internationally I there's there's no
circumstance in my mind where Hamas is
like n you're fine do whatever you want
no they probably said here's what we
expect from you here's what you have to
do and he says you got it well that's
what I'm saying I don't think the he's
not CNN's guy right this guy does work
for someone someone is paying his bills
to be there live there and exist there
and that's the question I want to have
answered is this guy part of Hamas is he
part of intelligence agency like how do
you get training to hang out with a moss
and not get shot right you have to buddy
buddy this is this is the question
picture of him getting kissed I mean
come on yeah right there that's crazy
and he's smiling and he's taking the
selfie yeah so it's not like they fa
they staged the photo he was like Hey
I'm going to get a picture with me and
this guy who's kissing me that's crazy I
mean but if he's Palestinian it would be
curious to hear what his personal view
on Hamas is anyways right I mean people
in in Palestine have a long and
complicated relationship with Hamas
because Hamas used to provide Social
Services I mean there was there was
Hamas pre what we know it it day it's
not that I'm justifying hamas's
existence but uh as a Palestinian
journalist maybe you view it differently
I don't know or maybe if he truly was
embedded and he truly is an
investigative journalist that's the role
he was playing you know or maybe that's
the story he's going to tell you either
way it's ridiculous but if he is
Palestinian right then he's subject to
hamas's whims yeah oh yeah I mean this
is this is propaganda yeah for them well
and also like he's just like a nice
journalist and I want to do a good job
and Hamas maybe I take your picture and
they know that he's ultimately going to
give the photos to CNN or to any kind of
Western Outlet there's a chance that
they're like yes of course we'll treat
you really nicely come on in because
again they ultimately you know there's
this question of material support So
Hamas may not be paying him but they do
want him to circulate images of them
Hamas has not been quiet about the fact
that they want public attention imagine
what would have happened if Hamas didn't
film any of what happened on October 7th
right there would be Li mited video from
security cameras and dash cams and some
people film stuff but a lot of the most
gruesome stuff we've seen they filmed
themselves mhm like killing civilians in
cars and stuff like that right they
wanted people to see what they were
doing yeah for sure that's messed up man
which is why they're ping around with
the press as well or is the Press look
man when you go to these protests in the
far left these quote unquote journalists
wearing press badges they're they're
activists they're antifa absolutely but
You' have have to look at like Tik Tok
right like Tik Tok has tons of V video
footage that's coming out on the ground
in Palestine right now of people in
Palestine saying you know Israel is
making us walk to the southern part of
the state or you know there is a counter
effort and so Hamas saying and this is
just off the cuff my opinion about it
but like Hamas saying yes we are willing
to show what we're doing kind of tells
the citizens yes you should also be
recording and trying to distribute
what's happening here as much as
possible and it makes the narrative more
complicated which is ultimately what
Hamas really wants yeah and I just also
want to stress that every government is
doing this at the same time to varying
degrees right but like gadoo is about to
show some film for the IDF you know
fight broke out everyone no yeah she had
a screening and a fight broke out
dressed up as Wonder Woman or she wasn't
at the fight but a fight broke out
outside the 1984 outfit not as good yeah
not as good not as good thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time